a few days ago I posted a video covering
the the game between Nakamura and Duda
which featured a really really beautiful
Queen sacrifice and today I want to show
another really beautiful Queen sacrifice
this time the white player is Timur
garea now one thing about this game was
garea was blindfolded and he was playing
16 games at once all keeping them in in
his mind it's a very impressive feats
he's the world record holder for for the
most number of games played at once
blindfolded I think the number is like
some absurd like 48 maybe close to 50
anyway this game deserves some kind of
brilliancy prize just because it's it's
so beautiful the finish is really really
nice so hopefully you guys will enjoy it
and without further ado let's get into
the game gary have started with already
opening night to f3 opponent played pawn
to d6 and i will say that the opponent i
couldn't find much information on based
on the the style of play it's clear that
black was an amateur but definitely
played reasonable enough to have the
game turn out to be a masterpiece so
going forward grey of play efore
transposing back into basically what's
appearance and after a pawn to e5 we
have a filled or defense and Philidor
has kind of a passive reputation it's
not so common among higher level play
simply because this pawn on d6 blocks of
Bishop from developing and in more
mainstream King's pawn opening the
bishop usually likes to come to c5
before black commits to d6 but play
continued pawn d4 knight c6 and Bishop
to b5 so white already having ideas
potentially winning the pawn potentially
playing d5
black responds naturally with Bishop to
d7 I like continues development Knight
c3 Bishop e7 and already White has kind
of a nice nice space advantage my
central control and I will say I really
admire the move that great played in
this position it it's probably normal to
play something like castling or Bishop
to e3 but he he wasted no time in going
for aggressive play and he played g4
here which in some respect is maybe a
pawn sacrifice the first moves to
analyze of course as Bishop takes g4 but
then white has perhaps a few different
options of course upon d5 is as the most
attractive and after a Pawnee six Bishop
a4 pawn v5y can take and it seems like
White's coming out on top and Miss lime
so going back after pawn g4 it is risky
for black to take the pawn and pawn g4
also tries to discourage an is-6 because
that would walk in to pawn g5 so play
continued black actually did play Knight
of 6 and gray of one I had in plays pawn
g5 chasing the night away from from the
most central square 9 h5 played and now
Rock g1 just adding more supports to the
pawn black plays a6
and white plays Bishop to c4 which I do
like this move I'm the bishop kind of
accomplished its goal on b5 and now it's
much happier targeting the f7 pawn now
black in this position played may be a
question we'll move Knight to f4
allowing white to simply take and then
go after the pawn on f4 which is quite
weak
perhaps box should have played something
else casting here looks pretty standard
even something like g6 but ok after what
was fighting the game that for
Bishop takes f4 and politics are for
Queen d2 and black has no way of
successfully defending the pawn so back
when I had here went for some
counter-attack pawn b5 white plays
Bishop to d5 and now black castles now I
will say it's really risky to castle in
this position with a bishop already
nicely placed the pawn on g5 and after
Queen takes f4 White has a lot of pieces
with potential to to organize some
attack and we're gonna see very soon how
White's completely breaks through blacks
defenses now the move played here is
rook to b8 which is kind of a slow move
I mean it's already difficult position
for black and it's it's really hard to
find a move here because White's
controlling so much center so much space
so hard to blame black for playing rugby
aids but now in this position I think
there's there's a very instructive
moment where okay white has nice kind of
setup with the pieces but it is a
question how to actually break through
and I would actually encourage viewers
to pause the video and try and find the
strongest continuation for whites
how can might make progress what would
be a nice plan or some way of generating
the threats feel free to pause and think
on your own
so hopefully you considered what what is
the strongest move and the move that
gray of played is pawn to g6 this is a
really really nice breakthrough move
normally when you're attacking you just
want to create more open lines for your
pieces and with this move this tries to
open the G file a pressure zaph pawn
which is pinned and of course takes
advantage of the fact that if the pawn
were to take back on g6 then the rook
can come into g6 and again that pawns
pinned
to the king queen each sixes of threats
and this is very very dangerous for
Sherlock to deal with so in the game
after g6 black played of a really sad
passive move up to Yates which is just
an attempt to kind of curl up in a ball
and hold on and and and pray for dear
life but after Bishop e8 this allowed
White's to play a really sensational
move and I was actually scrolling
through Instagram the other day and I
came across the the the position after
White's next move it was under Timur
graves Instagram feed and I'll link it
in the description along with the link
to the the rest of the games from this
this event but anyway whites a move
again feel free to pause the video and
find the really really nice move for
white and I'm just realizing that the
following positions probably going to be
the thumbnail so congratulations if you
if you remember the thumbnail and and
can identify the next move anyway
white played just the brilliance the the
reminiscent this is very reminiscent of
the the do they game where you just put
your your Queen on a square or an
opponent pawn can take it and I think
this is one of the most beautiful types
of moves in chess where like that one of
the the weakest chess men can take the
strongest piece but as we'll see it does
not work out for black and to show what
happened in the game black did take the
Queen white went ahead takes on f7 with
double check the King has to move to h8
and after rook g8 rook takes g8 the
Queen basically comes back to life in
the form of the promoted pawn and the
game ends with with a very nice chat
um so anyway this is a really really
nice finish just to show one more line
if the queen is not taken let's say the
pawn is taken then why it's not gonna
move the Queen why just comes in with a
rook and both of these pawns are pinned
to the King F pawn pinned by the bishop
sheep on pinned by the rook and whites
threatening mates and I'm getting a
phone call
oh no it's ringing everywhere okay sorry
about that where was I
yeah the attack is in full swing
White's threatening mate in in one the
only defense for black is Bishop f6 and
then White has a really nice move here
Knight g5 just threatening made on each
seven the Bishop is tied down to g7 this
is just mate next move if Bishop takes
g5 then mates if anything else then
Queen eight seven mates so really nice
game by garea and just this is a type of
move Queen age six so I move that you
don't get to play too many times and in
a lifetime so kudos to grave for for
winning this game I think overall he won
15 out of the 16 games and there's a
whole broadcast on YouTube and only has
55 views follow I'll link it below I'll
give a small preview of what it looks
like it's just the the broadcasts with
garea on a bicycle here I'll give it a
thumbs up
so anyway people can can check that out
and and look up more about gray if he's
a fascinating chess playing creature but
but yeah with that hope you guys enjoy
that um feel free to leave a comment
like what what sort of content you want
to see more of you want to see more game
analysis do you want to see more botas
gambits
or opening content let me know in the
comments
below be sure to subscribe I'm I'm doing
my best to put out videos every day
so if you subscribe you'll you'll
remember to watch every day and yeah
with that I'll see you in the next video